cet enfant de le transformer carole dubé
vient de perdre sa conjointe la mère de
ses sept enfants
à 37 ans joyce et chaque one était
hospitalisé à joliette pour des douleurs
à l'estomac
on voit quelle qu'elle demande de l'être
sur facebook
et quel personnel et dégradants et la
filmer une vidéo depuis son lit
d'hôpital [ __ ] avant de mourir elle
lance un appel à l'aide du baobab
venez me chercher il me drogue
s'écrie-t-elle mais le personnel
soignant qui vient à son chevet
l'insultent des propos discriminatoires
et racistes qui choque je suis indigné
contre une enquête du coroner est en
cours pour faire la lumière sur le drame
une autopsie sera pratiquée pour
déterminer les causes de la mort le 6 de
lanaudière assure qu'une autre enquête
est aussi menée alain termes que c'est
totalement inacceptable
une vague d'indignation qui atteint la
classe politique
aujourd'hui on demande la justice pour
jaurès on ne peut pas accepter ça au
québec et qui ramène à l'avant plan les
problèmes de racisme au québec
je pense qu'il ya du racisme au québec
il faut
combattre ce racisme l'infirmière ce
qu'elle dit c'est totalement
inacceptable et c'est raciste et elle a
été congédié un autre cas de la trop
longue série de drames que vivent les
autochtones de fini la récréation
j'ai fini là les bons lots puis faut que
ça change
après la commission vient on voit que
les choses bougent pas pour nous autres
mais qu'est ce qu'on attend d'autres
personnes ensemble d'une même voix ils
réclament du changement la justice pour
joyce et si jacques andré charbonneau
radio-canada joliette